what's up
hey
Betty
[Applause]
all right
baby who's a little baby
Mom hey how are you oh my brother I'm my
grandson
grandson wow
where's that I'm from Wyoming County how
far is that uh
20 20. yeah
hey Ray
how's your body right
's got some new shoes
oh yeah we're a little late today
right
all right
foreign
I'm late I'm late you're right
there's construction on your road so we
were slow there's construction on your
road yeah
yeah let's slow this down a bit
so who wants to go to the fair
who's going to be everybody except for
you
we can probably fit a lot of you guys
we'll see
how are you beautiful I'm good how are
you you remember Lauren
are you ready
now you girl
we were dancing together last time
where's your dog that uh they got hurt
good where's the dog that got hurt yeah
he's in the house
hi he's hiding yeah
yeah hi Lorraine
it's hard when you're missing the front
paw isn't it
you still Chase his cars
didn't slow him down huh nope
down now
have you guys been to the county fair
before
has anyone here been to the county fair
before I mean the state fair the State
Fair
you've been
what kind of what kind of stuff they got
going there
[Music]
and I got one of those what are you
calling
they got all kinds
I'm not getting them first
you can run the thing with the horses on
it and stuff yeah
you know one of the things that you wind
up and it goes around with all the
horses on it and bounces off and stuff
that's what that is it's just like the I
don't know I always say goodbye
who's this
what's his name
what's his name Braxton Braxton
whoa so this is Larry this is your
right your grandson great grandson
that's right
he
got another girl
Randy got another girl too oh you got
another girl yeah
I see yeah
you guys start young here
you guys start young here yeah
are you working uh yeah where do you
work I work uh we're doing for dear
Virginia
excellent
Timmy what are you working on what are
you working on yeah
come in front of you Carter what are you
doing right
now
he's tired
great we're gonna have some fun today
we're gonna have some fun yeah the fan
feels nice
[Music]
Lorraine make yourself at home yeah
just relax
don't say the word
I thought it was a boy
really bad
yeah that's what you're talking about
who made that page Paige down in uh in
Alabama yeah
one of the viewers that came to visit
you yeah everyone come visit me yeah
she's your friend now yeah she's my
friend she called me every day every day
and you had you had somebody from
California come visit you too recently
yeah a guy a guy came out with his wife
yeah the wife sat in the car and he came
out yeah right
how do you guys feel about all these
visitors
is all right yeah everyone's nice to you
right yeah it's all right to me that's
cool
when I got some more tea now
a dirty Ray
's hiding behind Kimmy right there
nice family shot
beautiful
boy
[Music]
are you ready
Lorraine's gonna sit on my left
Lorraine's gonna sit on my lap
[Laughter]
Regal Cinema you do that oh
well you pulling that knee forward
so tell me a little bit about your
brothers and sisters you are you the
youngest
who's the youngest
one who's the youngest of all the
brothers and sisters
who's the youngest youngest Papa
where are you idiot
hey Jacob
not that much
how old are you Grandpa who's me
Larry
I'll turn 65. I'm sorry he said seven
and there's there's a total of 15.
yeah 15 brothers and sisters 14 or 15.
Brothers how many brothers and sisters
yes I'm a girl
so 13.
oh I see mom have
15.
I hate younger than I am he's a no I'm
not I don't know what year were you born
1957 57 what year were you born
so you're you're older huh you're a year
older
who's the oldest
Ray is the oldest of all this right now
oh this boy but there were some old
others that passed away yeah so they
were older than Ray yeah yeah
camera the other one in our family is
kind
we just got one two three four systems
in the whole family
the ones I haven't met uh you know I met
Barbara and I met Freddie yeah but who
else
they are they died and went out oh I see
is there anyone still alive that I've
not met uh is there anyone still alive
that I have Brady would feel away but no
but no but still today today is there
anyone living without four right
thank you thank you
for 2006 and I'm not sure
it's round there somewhere
it was
thank God
foreign
where did they die of
yeah I'll have well farmer action
Brady has
I can't
right ahead block her high in his heart
you don't close up everything
and right now they can do to it
you know he died
Freddie was similar to Rey Freddy was
similar to Rey yeah
all right
yeah they're almost like uh
they were almost like almost twins yeah
but uh Freddy was mellower right he was
calmer yeah
really
well Ray used to be really rowdy
Freddy too oh yeah
go I'm too here I grew up I didn't raise
him half away I grew up
oh is that right
and them two go fishing yeah yeah
ready yeah we got back in this way
getting out of the car he grabbed a
baseball and it's like a while
he always had a bucket of one was ready
you guys have good memories of hanging
out with these guys and your kids
about seven years old we go up in there
and cut the trees down with a chainsaw
up in the hills
those times
I look forward to cutting them chainsaw
we're cutting them one out machete
what do you want
it's a good place to grow up no yeah
I like it
I hope y'all have fun
yeah we're gonna we're gonna do our best
for me
I'll get I'll get you a phone number too
okay I'll get you a phone number too all
right like you're a celebrity now you're
a celebrity now
when they call
I just
your life gotten better because of all
your uh the notoriety you guys have now
you guys are kind of famous
do you guys enjoy being
you're you're a little famous now people
know about you guys
no you're almost like a celebrity here
yeah
when you go to the Walmart or something
what happens
look at me too okay do I know you
I I don't know you
you know what's your name
I told her she said where you live at
I told her what I mean about you though
oh you're the guy you're like a
millionaire I apologize
everywhere I go somebody knows
figure it out
raise like on your bottom melon and I'm
gonna drop something like that Ray and
Timmy are like Elvis I think Ray and
Timmy are like Elvis
I must be driving no truck yeah I'd be
driving a brain you've tried he want her
to get her out of here
all right
you're right
her brother Ray come on people want to
see you come back
hey gets like this doesn't he
always stay at the house watch TV
[Music]
oh he wants to go
he wants to go to the fair well let's go
all right well let's go
come on
[Music]
foreign
I think we got Ray we got Lorraine we
got Kenneth
Timmy and Betty we got the whole gang
let's go to the fair
West Virginia State Fair yeah let's do
taser
you've had cotton candy before
I think
all right you guys we'll see you later
see you later man
see you later
Betty I barely recognize your house now
I barely recognize your house now
the new sighting the new roof yeah we
come around the corner I'm like that's
not their house
okay ray ready for a pit stop
we're almost there
[Music]
foreign
follow me
[Music]
right
sorry it's all right
thank you
show us on Facebook
[Music]
damn it
thank you
[Music]
everybody wants Pizza
all right
we're going this way
let me get some tickets
[Music]
okay I need seven arms okay
seven arms right here
one
ready put your put your hand in
you
do okay liver
put it right here put it right here
okay
okay let's do this
what do you want to go on Jimmy yeah
what do you want to go on look at this
no
how about this
do I do it
Timmy wants to go on this
[Music]
come on Ray
all right
[Music]
okay great
get in
[Music]
you know why I get in Ray
Mond
foreign
[Music]
all right
okay
it looks like Dad when he found out it
was seven more dollars okay come on you
gotta go give him a big hug because you
want to talk about money give your dad a
hug and that's what it was
wrong
you guys have fun thank you for playing
thank you okay so how many do we have
four entertainment I'm not sure how many
he was gonna do it well let me see how
many got one two three four o'clock five
I'll put all five moment okay here's
what we're gonna do guys
we're gonna take a dart
and we're gonna hold it like a pencil
There You Go sir
see that
throw it up there and pop a balloon
winner
winner you guys are good
[Music]
winner
you guys are good
these guys are good I think they cleaned
you no no
hold on
there you go sweetheart
yeah
oh my gosh okay
and don't worry sir it's only 80 more
dollars
look everybody picks out a mushroom
or a flamingo or a frog or a heavy base
or a unicorn what do you want
which one
all right how about that one you like a
frog
okay hold on
happy face happy face uh let me go yes
mushroom yes
you look kind of like you're laughing
like it hits perfect for him
all right thank you man oh thank you sir
thank you you guys have a great day I
got a tab oh thank you
come on up guys you guys have a great
time thank you
great job you guys
the whole family's good yeah
[Music]
there you go
everything okay yeah baby yeah there you
go
come here
hey are you ready to race
you don't want to go in the ferris wheel
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Timmy you having fun
[Music]
laughs
it's the highest you've ever been up
[Music]
we're up high yeah
yeah
look down here
we go TV
thank you
okay
now how long your life
I'll put your hand right there with that
boring
excuse me
here we go
[Music]
hurry up here yeah
what's that
oh
hey
you can't hear you way up here
[Music]
thank you
what do you think
everybody's playing here at the Dutchman
game and there's a prize every time
[Music]
foreign
let me know
did you have a good time yeah
mm-hmm